Hi World Economic Forum at Davos! My name is Augusto Molinero
and I am giving one idea that I think can drive inclusive growth.
How can everyone benefit from the global economy?
We need to produce much more wealth with drastically fewer resources.
How could we expect prosperity to spread
when economies from the less developed world
don't have access to basic best business practices
which have shaped the modern world for the past century?
My idea for getting 3 billion people out of poverty is entrepreneurship
and entrepreneurship can be taught to these people by using videos.
Making sure that that video is used for a purpose,
first of all to influence policy makers.
Put a TV in every house of the developing world.
If the developed world will provide them with the tools, they will
be able to create the opportunity for themselves and for others.
The opportunity for inclusive growth in the 21st century
will come from investing in and empowering
what I call the feminine leadership style.
In our opinion the most inclusive way to close the gap
is to share knowledge and experience.
Two heads are better than one!
And this is how we can bridge the poverty gap:
there is a three-step simple programme.
That’s why my goal is to create a Farmville for charity.
We can absolutely close the gap between the rich and the poor.
I am here on Wall street, asking folks how can Wall
Street help close the gap between the rich and the poor.
Sir, how can Wall Street help close the gap between the rich and the poor?
Actually your question is somewhat absurd on one side.
The gap between the poor and the rich can never actually really be closed.
Inclusive growth means expanding our conversations.
It means not just listening
but collaborating. Discussions about international issues.
Imagine a world where no one is left behind. Where
everyone has a voice and every voice is heard.
Inclusive dialogue for inclusive growth. Let’s turn
these 7 voices into 7 billion. Our generation is ready!